y llegó el momento de hablar de economía
para eso nos acompaña aquí en nuestro
estudio en Bogotá del periodista Jorge
Hurtado Jorge buenas noches bienvenido y
hoy usted me robó el color Así es
Estamos parejo no estamos parejos Jorge
empecemos hablando de la economía
estadounidense cuéntenos cómo avanzan
las discusiones sobre el techo de la
deuda bueno el presidente junto con el
presidente republicano de la cámara de
representantes Kevin mccarthy llevan
tres rondas de conversaciones negociando
este acuerdo que permitiría Elevar el
actual límite de endeudamiento para que
Estados Unidos pueda hacer frente a sus
actuales compromisos del gasto los
republicanos insisten en recortar el
gasto a cambio de Elevar este límite de
endeudamiento el presidente biden se
sentó a negociar tras negarse durante
meses pero dice que los republicanos
tendrán que dar marcha atrás a sus
posiciones extremas escuchemos a carín
Jean Pierre secretaria de prensa de la
Casa Blanca sobre las negociaciones y su
avanza
en la medida en que ambas partes
entiendan que ninguna va a conseguir
exactamente lo que quiere podremos
llegar a un acuerdo presupuestario
bipartidista y razonable
miren miren no voy a ir más allá de lo
que el presidente ha dicho lo ha dejado
muy claro no va a resolver nuestros
problemas Ahí es donde estamos el
congreso tiene que hacer su trabajo
tienen que hacer un trabajo que lleva
haciéndose desde 1960
Jorge y mientras Estados Unidos tiene
este debate interno en materia
internacional sigue la guerra comercial
con china concretamente por los
Microchips Y es que tras la prohibición
de Minecraft que era una noticia que
compartimos el día de ayer un legislador
ahora propone que la empresa China de
chips china
Memory technologies debería entrar en la
lista de restricciones comerciales de
Estados Unidos el presidente de la
comisión sobre china en la cámara de
representantes de ese país pidió el
departamento comercio de Estados Unidos
que la empresa china sea vetada en
Estados Unidos las coreanas Samsung y
también skynix con fábricas de chips en
China se salvaron de los nuevos
controles de exportación de Estados
Unidos Aunque sus licencias podrían
expirar o incluso ser revocadas en
cualquier momento las restricciones
impuestas por el regulador chino a
microon que es el mayor fabricante
estadounidense de chips son las últimas
una creciente disputa comercial entre
las dos mayores potencias económicas del
mundo bueno y el país que sí tiene una
noticia positiva es Reino Unido porque
el fondo monetario internacional está
diciendo que se prevé que continúe el
crecimiento bueno según el fmi Reino
Unido evitaría totalmente una recesión
en 2023 Aunque la perspectiva de
crecimiento es moderada al estimar que
el alza para este año estaría en torno
al 0,4% del producto interno bruto el
fmi asegura que un repunte en la demanda
ayudada también por un crecimiento en
los salarios un mayor gasto público y
una mejora sobre todo en la confianza
empresarial fueron claves para que esa
economía no cayera en recesión Durante
este año escuchemos
las autoridades británicas han tomado
medidas decisivas y responsables en los
últimos meses ella ha fomentado la
estabilidad macroeconómica y financiera
en una época de Gran volatilidad de los
mercados sus esfuerzos y el reciente
descenso de los precios de la energía
están empezando a repercutir
positivamente en la economía
bueno y hay una buena noticia para los
usuarios de Microsoft y es que a partir
de hoy pueden encontrar el chat gpt en
Bing bueno entre las novedades que
anunció Microsoft estarán los resultados
de búsqueda en directo de vine a través
de chat gpt que es este chatbook viral
de sus ocio openiyey según la compañía
brindará los resultados web de Bing para
los suscriptores de pago y pronto estará
disponible también para los gratuitos la
empresa anunció que está apostando por
los plugins para Bing utilizando
tecnología de openi permitiendo también
a las empresas realizar transacciones
fáciles con los consumidores en su motor
de búsqueda estas actualizaciones de
Bing son parte del esfuerzo de Microsoft
para captar el mercado de la publicidad
de búsquedas que se estima ronda los 286
mil millones de dólares en valor de
Mercado en todo el planeta bueno y ahora
hablemos de Apple porque esta compañía
anunció un multimillonario acuerdo con
para producir Microchips a propósito de
la guerra comercial con esto Apple
aumenta el suministro estadounidense con
el que quiere ser menos dependiente de
la cadena de suministros exteriores el
acuerdo del que no trascendió cifras
será de varios años y dijeron que va a
permitir a bradcom continuar invirtiendo
en proyectos de automatización
mejorandolos con ingenieros y también
técnicos Apple aseguró que el acuerdo
ayudará a la creación de puestos de
trabajo en Estados Unidos en un mundo
Cada vez más dominado por las empresas
asiáticas en la industria de chips y
todo tipo de componentes electrónicos la
empresa Brad con desarrollará también
compon de radiofrecuencia 5g incluidos
los filtros firmware que son un tipo de
Microchips específicos para las
comunicaciones con esta movida Apple
quiere reducir su dependencia de China
por los riesgos que representa
justamente esa tensa relación entre
Estados Unidos y el gigante asiático
Jorge Cuál es la cifra de este martes
6,2 millones de dólares en eso se vendió
en una subasta de Hong Kong un reloj
patek Philip que usó el último emperador
chino hay sin goro puy la subasta duró
siete minutos y se realizó en la sede de
Philip en Hong Kong además de haber
pertenecido al último monarca de la
dinastía King de este reloj solamente
hay ocho ejemplares en el mundo cuenta
con fases lunares y también calendario
de triple fecha Bueno entonces si solo
hay ocho yo me voy a apurar a comprar el
suyo Dale lo espero para mi cumpleaños
bueno sígalo esperando Jorge yo le digo
que hasta aquí la economía y volvemos
con más en una hora Gracias
vale Y nosotros continuamos con el
debate